[Music]
first of all I know this is completely
off topic with your career what you're
up to but I have to ask you as a member
of the British Empire are you excited
about the whole Royal baby
uh I'm chuffed I think it's fantastic
chef I'm chuffed us of our English word
it means I'm really pleased I'm very
happy for them all okay um yeah I'm a
bit of a royalist and I think it's nice
I like a baby obviously baby myself so
it's a good to it a good thing were you
happy within a choice of name they went
with George is very traditional um which
is fine I think a baby called Regent
prime would be weird
yeah Eliot or something I think it'll be
yeah so you think they went with the
right name yeah I think it's the Queen's
father isn't it George yeah it was Ben
this will be the seventh George I think
so yeah there's one more than Fast &
Furious movies I can't remember that's
all I could hear now I want to tell you
have a your you're terrific
actor you're very funny and you have a
no I'm sorry go go I'm serious but sure
you have a particular following very
excited following yeah in the gay
community sure yeah can you tell us
about that
what is the Bears essentially um it's
embarrass big guys who like big hairy
guys it's a very it's a niche market but
I think if I can't if I can't attract
the 25 to 35 year old women I'll take
the the 40 plus giant hairy men yeah so
there so so and how do you know this you
know this because they they send you a
hat is it through social media that you
use there's a lot lot of tweets from big
hairy guys and oh my god you're so high
yeah they might not spin like that but I
think but I think I'd love to pose on
the cover of all-american bear I think
that would be great is that a real is
that a Magus I think is a magazine and
I've even got like a little outfit that
I think I'd wear I don't have it on your
have you backstage but it's essentially
white chaps a kind of white cowboy vest
in a tiny little cowboy hat let's
I think that's terrific and I think I'd
have two little revolvers yeah shut
it'll kill you okay now you are not a
classically trained actor but you're
very good you you believe that your job
which you came up with this is your own
philosophy was to do as little as
possible yeah when you're acting yeah
that's about that well you know I mean I
just felt kind of fill my way through
the acting business but I did a job once
where we had lots of people who weren't
actors on a film called kinky boots
which I think just won a bunch of awards
in on Broadway and I watched these guys
who weren't actors and and they didn't
do a thing I mean not a thing they just
they just did that and I think this I
thought that was that was amazing you
couldn't teach that you couldn't teach
that no because I mean essentially I
think actors are kind of show offs and
they want everyone to see what they're
doing and you know but if you look at
people with look at us now I mean apart
from me because I'm doing that we're
kind of not doing anything you know yeah
I think less is more when it comes to it
and it will probably right I have to be
honest if I'm not an actor but if I were
an actor an hour in movies I know I'd be
doing too much yeah I know that that
would be my ten I'd be a lot of like
even if my job was just to take a sip
I'd be like
you know I'd be fired immediately
yeah I mean that guy I mean there is a
place for the ocean not in films